[Music]
welcome ladies and gentlemen to yet
another special berlin science week
event this time in cooperation with the
berlin university alliance and the
european research council it's about the
transformative effect of science
quite a promise
and sometimes me even a threat a promise
over the course of history and
especially within the last 200 years
science has brought
enormous improvements to the way we live
even more so and more rapidly in the
last 50 years or so we use technologies
people were not able to imagine
a few decades ago
we are in the middle of an energy
revolution we are able to fight formally
deadly diseases and we managed to
survive with 8 billion people on this
planet
and a planet that has been inhabited by
a few hundred million for millions for
almost all of history
a danger
also because of our progress the earth
is sick as we all know we are on the
verge of ecological political and
societal breakdowns because we are a
global society
new diseases can spread quickly as we
have experienced and we are not able to
control them in time
sometimes
it seems that for one solution science
delivers
there is at least a new challenge
at least one news challenge
is it that what we mean
when we talk about the transformative
effect of science
or are we just getting started
will science lead us into a new more
sustainable future
so
let's talk about science
let's talk about the places where it
happens the universities
and the network is a promise that is a
promise too about the berlin science
university alliance the berlin
university alliance tonight
we are going to learn more about the
research being done by the bua
universities and how it is being
stimulated by the alliances
as well as by the european research
council my name is yamadin viada i'm a
journalist for education and research
and as a moderator tonight i'm happy to
give the floor now to professor dr
zabina kunst she's the president of the
homeboard university
and the speaker of the berlin university
alliance sabina kunst great to have you
here
[Applause]
thank you
martin viada for the kind introduction
dear president leptin
the erc grantees dear colleagues dear
friends of the university
alliance ladies and gentlemen i have the
i have the privilege to beat you welcome
here in this fantastic location in the
name of the berlin university alliance
to the joint event of the european
research council
we are very proud that you mrs leptin
are with us here today as your first
visit to berlin in your new role as
president of the european research
council professor leptin has started her
new
role only a couple of days ago on the
first of november
and i'm very curious about the talk she
will provide us
the erc is one of the most prestigious
scientific funding institutions
worldwide it provides funding for ideas
created by scientists in a bottom-up
approach
funding for basic fundamental funding
research
receiving a grant by the erc is
certainly one of the crown jewels of
scientists
the title of the session today is the
transformative effect of science
why should we discuss about this as
researchers
we want also to show
how our scientific effort contributes to
effectively transforming our societies
for universities this effort can be
labeled there's through admission going
beyond research and teaching
only a few developments have shown
that drastically the value of research
than the covet pandemic and the rapid
devolution
evolution of vaccines with the help of
the erc as we all know however if we
consider the developments with regard to
the research funding europe still lags
behind other continents
fundamental research is sometimes under
pressure by policy makers
the expectation exists science should
help them solve the difficulties and
pressing needs the great challenges of
today
and indeed
this is the main tenant of the berlin
university alliance contribute to the
solution of complex global problems and
the search for interdisciplinary answers
the showcase
the value of furniture research we need
to become much better at explaining the
complex relationship between science and
society fundamental research is often so
specific that even other academics have
difficulties in understanding the
essence and the results may seem
irrelevant at this time of their finding
but in the course of time they may
become revolutionary
all science effectively relies on the
insight provided by prior fundamental
science
universities and public research
institutions perform more than three
quarters of total basic research and to
ensure continued support for basic
research
we made we need to make sure that it is
understood that fundamental science
serves to learn to understand how things
work and to push the boundaries of human
knowledge further
it is necessary to provide fundamental
researches with the trust
time and resources to allow them to
contribute their dedication and turn
ideas into scientific breakthroughs
the funding system of the erc is one
example of doing this
the berlin university lines is a vibrant
partnership and each of the four
institution is proud to have a number of
erc grantees
four of them will provide you with a
brief insight into the essence of their
projects and give you very distinct
examples of the transformative potential
of fundamental science professor riley
professor schneider professor bikum and
professor surika
but before they will have the word i'm
very much looking forward to hear your
words mrs leptin about the rule of
science and the european research
council
i'll hand the micro back to jan martin
viada who will briefly introduce the
next steps of the event today
[Applause]
thank you very much sabine kunst
and now it's a huge honor for me to
introduce professor dr maria leptin to
you this as sabine quince has just
pointed out is
one of her first official appearances as
the new president of the european
research council since she has taken
office just five days ago
prior to that she served as director of
the european molecular biology
organization bringing together 1 800
leading researchers she also established
a research group in heidelberg at the
emblem
the erc
as
you all know has proven to be the beacon
of excellence of european research
policy professor
will speak now about how science is
related to technology innovation
practical application and growth and why
science is so central for addressing the
many societal challenges that lie ahead
and also so central for creating a
sustainable future
maria leptin everybody
[Applause]
thank you
leave a college
dear colleagues and friends in the
audience dear erc grantees the most
exciting part of this evening ladies and
gentlemen
i'm delighted to be here as part of this
berlin week it's a great opportunity to
celebrate science and i'm glad that we
could put this event together with the
berlin university alliance i
specifically want to
thank my predecessor jean-pierre
bouguino who's here in the audience and
professor quintet ziegler from the
friend visited for having mediated this
and of course johannes fogel for
allowing us to be in this fantastic
space here
and indeed i'm proud that this is my
first event as president of the european
research council i've spent three days
in brussels the first two days of the
week were holidays
so for those of you who don't know me
i'm a development biologist and
immunologist my career has taken me
throughout europe and the us
and uh now to brussels
one of my aims will be to build greater
appreciation of what the erc does and to
foster a more positive attitude towards
research in all fields among all
citizens in europe
and one of the approaches of that will
of course be communicating better the
success of erc grantees
the ultimate proof of what the erc does
after all is the work of our grantees
and so i'm really delighted to have four
of them here
and look forward to listening to them
jean-pierre my predecessor realized and
also made it clear to me that the best
ambassadors for the erc are in fact the
brilliant researchers that we support
so like i said citizens in all countries
in europe should know what their erc
grantees are doing what they're finding
out and should take great pride in them
but i'm here today to talk about science
in general and why society should
support it
science is at its core
the attempt to understand the world
around us and how that world functions
i for one believe that this alone is a
worthwhile end and that's what will be
my theme
throughout my tenure
i understand it may sometimes be
difficult to persuade governments and
citizens to support us at the levels
that they do and that i believe are
minimally necessary
if
understanding was the only result of
research
let me also be clear that when i say us
or we
i don't mean only the natural sciences
but all academic research even though i
will focus today on the natural science
i want to make it clear that i can
consider curiosity driven research in
all other fields too philosophy
archaeology economics
psychology so humanity social sciences
everything
important and of interest for all
citizens and their governments
governments do of course support arts
and research into humanities to some
extent in germany we're very lucky we
have good funding
but nothing like the level that they
support the natural sciences
and that's what today's topic is about
so let's ask
what do people actually want from the
natural sciences
i think mainly they
if they're asked what output they want
they want improvements in their standard
of living and that's largely based on
material of wealth
now econom economists have of course
been studying the factors that create
worlds the factors of production land
labor
capital for over 200 years
only in the last century
did it become clear
that not all of the historical growth in
production and wealth can be explained
through existing knowledge
but a large component
requires
a new factor in production namely
technological
progress
imagine for instance a farmer that can
grow enough food to feed him and his
family i say him and his family because
it was only men at the time um
but
and then
they can produce enough food for
themselves
add another farmer they can produce
twice as much but per farmer it remains
the same
but if you give them capital for
instance a plow then they become more
efficient more effective and grow more
give them two plows now they can both do
more but eventually give them more plows
and their children can help but
eventually you will saturate the world
with plows and you cannot make further
progress and they then have to look for
something better something new
to continue to improve
better tractor or perhaps fertilizers or
genetically engineered plants
so real growth per capita
in wealth ultimately comes from new
technology and that's what the citizen
is interested in
but where does that technology come from
ultimately all technologies
use natural phenomena we work with
nature they're based on nature we can't
just invite anything we can dream of
that's what movie makers and science
fiction writers do but we know that that
can't work and there have been some
hilarious predictions from those that
just
couldn't have worked in the first place
so it's science and building our
understanding of the world whether it's
the physical world the living world or
the human world
that allows us to create new
technologies
what gives science its transformative
impact is that
by understanding the world we can change
the world and only by understanding it
now this is not something that we've
discovered in the recent past
in preparing this um talk with a
wonderful policy analyst at the erc um
ben turner
ben came up with a number of
illuminating quotes from four centuries
that i'll i will use to illustrate this
performing before getting back to what
we can want or should do today
scientists have seen from the beginning
the importance of understanding how the
world functions
so bacon argued in 1620 that i quote as
a wonderful quote
nature can only be commanded by obeying
her he didn't even say understanding but
obeying her we have to use what nature
gives us
to
control nature
he went on to say
that by pursuing science humanity would
be raised above the conditions of
helplessness poverty and misery while
coming into condition of peace
prosperity and security so he saw the
use of understanding the world
the very positive and optimistic view of
course
a couple of hundred years later the
marquis de condorcet
gave further expression to this optimism
in his sketch for a historical picture
of the progress of human of the human
mind
he predicted unlimited progress not only
in science technology but in morality
and society he wrote about the equality
of the racists and the sexes and peace
between nations more than 200 years ago
again huge optimism and uh we wish it
had come out all that way russell albert
um sorry albert russell wallace a
contemporary of darwin's who also worked
with garmin darwin on
evolution called his book about his
century the wonderful century again this
optimism and this
appreciation for what science could do
for humanity
of course this naive optimism and
confidence was
shattered a bit
by the events of the last century
actually already the 19th century but
the wars in the last century were of
course um a death knell to this uh
yeah childlike optimism
where it turned out that technical and
material progress did not automatically
lead to moral progress or an end to wars
instead science even produced the
terrible new weapons that did so much
damage
so that's why the last century
scientists began to be more circumspect
and i want to quote enrico fermi when he
talked about science in the 20th century
he said some of you may ask what is the
good of working so hard merely to
collect a few facts which will bring no
pleasure except to a few long-haired
professors
because only few specialists at best
will be able to understand them
in answers to such questions i may
venture a fairly safe prediction history
of science and technology has
consistently taught us that scientific
advances in basic understandings the
understanding have sooner or later led
to technical and industrial applications
that have revolutionized a way of life
he warned what is less certain and what
we all fervently hope
is that man will soon grow sufficiently
adult to make good use of the powers
acquired over nature again i don't think
we've seen this growing up fully
but we must retain hope but here we are
at the start of the 21st century
faced with the realization that our own
actions have been causing irreparable
damage to nature and to warming of the
act
atmosphere with dire repercussions for
our planet on our way of life
given this it is perhaps not so
surprising that some purple people turn
against science and the idea of progress
and the goal of economic growth
but let's not forget that there has been
progress and that many of the dreams of
the enlightenment have come to pass
many of us live in unprecedented levels
of material comfort and health compared
to our ancestors and again we mustn't
forget this when we think about
research and intellectual um
activity as a cultural
activity
that we can afford europe can afford to
do this
and this is not just uh this progress is
not just a ritual phenomenon in eighteen
hundred forty three percent of the
world's newborns died before their fifth
birthday it was perfectly normal to lose
every other child
in 1960 child mortality was around 20
percent
over the last the last decades it's gone
down to four point three percent in rich
countries sometimes as low as one
percent and note that that percentage
does not correlate with wealth alone
so there's also a role of politicians
for using what science does
some of our richest uh countries
are not as low as one percent
so maybe bacon and condorcet have not
have been at least partly proven right
in their optimism
and justify us
retaining our optimism
at the same time while we acknowledge
this progress we have to admit that we
still face tremendous challenges
we can acknowledge that many of the
problems we face are of our own making
and at the same time
trust that we can solve them
let's remember the original goal of
science namely to understand the world
in the context of what to do with
scientific findings and that's under
that understanding let's quote richard
feynman
scientific knowledge enable us to do all
kinds of things and to make all kinds of
things scientific knowledge is an
enabling power
knowledge is an enabling power to do
either good or bad but it does not carry
instructions on how to use it that has
to come from elsewhere
so as scientists we must understand this
power
that our findings have but we must also
accept our responsibility for the ways
in which our findings are used creating
a culture of ethics and integrity in
research is as important
as fostering a spirit of inquiry that's
what i've really tried to push in my
former role as mbo director the erc has
tried to push they're really exemplary
and we all must continue to push
together
of course we can and must be part of the
solution of the problems we face now and
we are
remember it was the scientists who first
detected global warming
and science must
play its part in trying to reach a new
equilibrium
equilibrium we must actively undo what
we've done
i do not doubt that new and improved
technologies can make major
contributions to addressing some of the
many challenges we face
but
from the social sciences and humanities
we can also contribute new ideas new
insights new theories and new algorithms
about how to live sustainably how to
confront inequality how we might work
and live and educate ourselves together
in future
so there's also a potential problem with
this uh
thought of freedom of inquiry
since the earliest days scientists have
fought for freedom and inquiry among
current exam examples of uh institutions
that really promote this are for example
here in germany the max planck society
which operates on the so-called harnac
principle which is named after alfred
von hanak the first president of the
predecessor of max planck society sorry
the kaiser wilhelm society he advocated
the right of researchers to work
independently of government and
or private requirements and unencumbered
by bureaucracy thankfully and to this
day that's what max planck does it
builds up it's built around individual
researchers who themselves define their
research subjects are given the best
working condition and freedom
in the uk
in 1918 richard burton haldane from the
big spread and famous holding germany
chaired a committee which produced a
report recommending that general
research should be under the control of
autonomous
research councils those should be free
from political and administrative
pressures that might discourage research
in certain areas
and in the u.s a 1945 report to the
president of the united states called
for an expansion of government support
for science and the creation of the
national scientific
national science foundation
venevar bush in his piece science the
endless frontiers stated scientific
progress on a broad front results from
the free play of free intellects working
on subjects of their own choice
in the manner dictated by their
curiosity for exploration of the unknown
freedom of inquiry must be preserved
under any plan for for government
supportive science what is statement
maybe that's why the us is doing so well
in research
now the erc operates according to
similar principles
it supports excellent scientists from
anywhere in the world of any age and
from any field in research including the
social sciences and humanities there are
no predetermined targets or quotas it
provides substantial long-term funding
for up to five years the only conditions
are that erc-funded research must be
based in europe
and be adventurous and take risks
this approach can be confusing to
politicians policymakers and
administrators they're under pressure to
deliver results in the short term
all the more so when we are convinced uh
uh confronted with major crisis like now
it's very promising to
to it's very tempting to promise to fund
scientists to solve climate change it's
much harder to say we will fund
scientists to devol to develop new
knowledge
scientists understand this political
pressure for
immediate results
and that there are indeed many pressing
problems
in the world
they share these views
so why do funders such as erc not set
priorities and struck our grantees to
solve specific problems
this is certainly not because we care
more or other organizations care more
about the needs of scientists than the
needs of society in fact like i said
researchers share the concern and the
desire for solutions
but the philosophy of the erc rests on
the idea that researchers know best the
most promising research areas to
explore i'll give you an example of that
i chaired the erc synergy grant panel a
couple of years ago or three years ago
wonderful grants they are
multi-disciplinary
and our panel was composed it covered
the whole breadth of the life sciences
and was composed about with people who
represented the life sciences it turned
out that the grants that had come in the
applications had come in were there were
an exceptional number on the environment
population biology interaction of beings
with their environment evolution
etc etc
mind-boggling and we did not have
anywhere near expertise on the committee
for this onslaught of grants in a new
field because this was new and it just
turned out that the best grants by the
best scientists were on pressing
problems or on establishing the basis
the basic knowledge of problems for
problems that we would need to find
solutions
so we don't need to tell them they vote
with their feet
so
putting all our resources into
so one of the major aims as a new
president of the erc will be to fight
for sufficient funding for frontier
research
if we look at the journey which got us
the mrc vaccines that's another example
we don't we need to look no further it
was
independent basic research that was
immediately deployed with amazing speed
to find vaccines
this is not unusual any technology or
project or service that we use at the
moment is a combination of many
components each of these has its own
story often going way into the distant
future
the idea of combination of technologies
and the findings may sound trivial
or obvious but it isn't it's important
to understand because with each new
understanding we acquire we now have the
possibility of combining it with all
other knowledge we already had this is
called combinatorial explosion
and again this is what's promoted by
allowing scientists to do what they
think is most important and just
providing elements that others
if they so wish can use to turn into
application
once we understand the combinatorial
nature of technology and we can see why
science innovation and techno
technological progress are not linear
each feeds on the other in a constant
series of feedback loops there is no
point at which the science stops and the
so-called innovation begins
problem is when policy makers start to
believe that they can simply order
researchers to come up with whatever
they think is necessary
then we end up with absurdities such as
researchers being asked uh when they ask
for funding please tell us what
discovery you are going to make a
contradiction in in terms if you know
what you're going to discover it can't
be a discovery
um and which societal challenge you will
solve
so i've argued that the transformative
event of science comes from discovering
and understanding
and thereby being manipulate an even
greater detail natural phenomena
phenomena combining these understandings
together in ever new and in predicted
and unpredictable ways is another major
way forward
it's been clear that researchers must
have freedom to explore these phenomena
that is why funding cannot be
short-sighted to maintain a healthy
research system it is right to invest in
long-term curiosity-driven research
some consider this approach to be
idealistic and it is idealistic of
course it is idealistic but it is also
necessary
in order for science to have its maximal
impact for the benefit of society and as
long as i'm pre president of the erc i
will continue to make this
argument and do it as long as it takes
to be heard
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much maria lepin if you
would like to stay with me for a minute
here there might be some questions we
have like five minutes or so if you
would like to take some questions from
the audience if there are any i have a
question anyways but
i would like to give you the opportunity
professor ziegler
there should be a microphone somewhere
here there is a microphone
there's the microphone
perhaps it's too early to ask but
the question will be of course whether
you feel that the european commission
and so have understood or value the
the value of basic research which in the
end uh drives things um
perhaps you'll just watch that
you've of course hit the nail on the
head it will depend on them what the
next um
the next framework program
you know will allow us to do and how
much money they will allocate
um
many politicians are very enlightened
and are happy to uh to see this of
course not everybody i think but you
know politicians
listen to their constituencies their
constituencies are their voters the
voters are the citizens in the countries
and i actually believe that
people have an inherent
appreciation of curiosity you know
people care about black holes even
though they do them no good people care
about how how the las koppe
caves were painted what paint was used
they care about they read kahneman
thinking slow thinking fast that's it
you know he he developed this while
walking around campus paid a nice salary
but they care so i think it can be made
clear to everyone that the value of base
and i'm deliberately quoting those
things that don't have an immediate um
uh
impact i think there is room to convince
the citizens in europe that to remind
them
of the value of basic and qrs to
different research and that's the way
can't be done overnight
new methods for reaching them will have
to be found um but we're exploring that
let me just follow up on that who's in
charge of who has to to
convince voters in europe that basic
science is just as important as you say
the research researchers themselves the
research organizations the politicians
who is in charge of actually building up
this trust everybody every everybody you
named and you know it's very nice to the
erc grantees are actually very good in
in in helping and engaging with and john
pierre has found ways of
of communicating science so i think
everybody
many research organizations actually
force their grantees to do public
outreach which i think is good and some
scientists are very good at it but some
are not very good at it some are very
good at sitting in their dark room and
thinking or you know should they be
forced to i i don't i think there's no
point i think there are people who are
good communicators you probably are one
so there are people who are
journalists bloggers movie makers you
know everybody listens to attenborough
now
there there must be people out there and
i know there are people out there and i
think engaging with them it also has to
be done in the national language so
there's nobody no point in somebody
sitting in brussels and and lecturing so
i think it requires a long-term approach
hopefully helped by our grantees but
also helped by engaged journalists and i
know they're there
would you agree with that agree that the
overall trust into science in europe is
pretty high still
i think it varies a lot i mean we and
it's not you know i mean come on you
know this i guess we're not quite as bad
as the us in uh being seduced by fake
news i think education in many places is
good and trains people to critical
thinking
but
you know you have to be on the lookout
all the time
ultra important ultra important to give
children the basic understanding of what
science does and how it works
thank you
never enough
go ahead
wonderful
i have a general question so science and
education are two things which never can
be fully separated and probably
shouldn't be
and but sometimes in europe uh those
scientists who educate most of the
students most of the future scientists
and not living in the institutions that
necessarily provide the best
framework for doing science so what's
your view and this and what's dsc able
to do
to improve that situation i think the
erc can't do anything it's a structural
problem in in
and again it's it's it's national you
know the the us howard hughes system
uh which is equally generous and uh
as the erc funds researchers within
universities the max planck society
funds
researchers outside universities in some
places i mean i know germany well i am
german um
that uh
you know there's good connections but
not everywhere i agree with you the top
scientists should be in in
close to training institutions
but really i think the most important
step is actually at school
thank you we have time for one more
question if there is one
all right
then we'll just move on to the
presentation thank you so much maria
leptin
[Applause]
so erc is about funding science so
basically it's about real science and
now it's time to hear about some real
science projects about some research
that has been do has been done or has
been being done by researchers or
grantees and grantees erc grantees let's
learn about four concrete examples of
excellent research all from berlin
four erc grantees one from each
partner university what is the
transformative effect to their science
we will find out now and it's also a
special challenge for the researchers
their research is complex but they only
have seven minutes each to explain it
and they must be very focused because
they're only allowed to use a few slides
without much text
so not the way they would normally
present their research but they all took
on the challenge and i'm really excited
to present them to you
and we will just get started with
matthias relic and just for all those
who present
um those seven minutes you know i will
stand up after five minutes so then you
know you have two minutes left
and let me introduce matthias riley to
you he's professor of ecology at the
freya universitat berlin his team
addresses a range of questions related
to global change bio diversity and
terrestrial ecosystems especially soil
he received an erc advance grant for his
project
gradual change today he will be talking
about multiple factors professor
matthias relic everybody
[Applause]
yeah thanks a lot good evening i'm
pretty excited to be talking to you
today about um this topic has just been
mentioned and we currently hear a lot
about climate change i mean currently
the cop 26 conference is going on and
you hear the news all the time and i
have
this presentation but i also have one
mission and that mission is that i want
you to think more about global change
rather than climate change this is the
one thing i would like to take you home
take that you take home with you and so
here's why so we of course climate
change is a super important topic
but we do a lot more to this planet than
just change the climate
have invasive species we have elevated
atmospheric co2 concentrations we have
atmospheric nitrogen deposition we have
microplastic all kinds of chemical
pollution the list goes on and on
and this is also important to take into
account
now what we did to start is we looked at
the literature we looked at a couple
thousand papers
and
we
screened for how many factors are people
actually examining in experiments in
terms of global change and soil and
terrestrial ecosystems
i don't know if you can guess
how many factors people generally
examined in their papers
98.2
of all papers ever published on global
change
did one or two
so
only a super tiny proportion of all
papers by scientists ever published from
experimental work looked at more than
two factors that's pretty crazy because
we know that soils and terrestrial
ecosystems are going to be affected by a
whole range of factors think for example
about urban soils here in berlin or
agricultural systems
so you might also ask why is that why is
that so why do people not study more
than two factors well the reason is
actually the combinatorial explosion
problem that you mentioned that is like
when you sit around a table looking at a
mathematician right there this is like
the number of clinks between the glasses
of people sitting around the table it
goes up very very rapidly with the
number of people sitting around the
table so if you're looking at 10 factors
10 factors drivers of global change you
have 2 to the power 10 combinations if
you only look at two levels of each
factor that's 1024
different treatment combinations and
nobody can do an experiment like this
so what did we do
we did a little trick
we asked a slightly different question
but i did an experiment with 10 factors
that's shown here
and what i did is i had a pool of 10
factors
and
i
sampled randomly from that pool of 10
factors a given number of factors along
a gradient of increasing number of
factors going from zero the control to
one two five eight and all ten so in in
factor level two for example i randomly
pulled two global change factors for my
pool maybe microplastic and warming this
was replicate number one second
replicate was maybe salinity and
herbicide second replicate so all of the
replicates of the factor level two had
different combinations of factors this
is actually a pretty crazy experiment
it's never been done you're literally
comparing apples and oranges and my
expectation was what would come out is
chaos
but what came out the result was not
chaos at all it was super surprising
what we found and i'm told show no
graphs of data and whatever so i'm going
to show you that's going to have to
believe me but it was a very straight
line an unusually straight line for an
ecological study with so many factors
active
that decreased with the number of
factors that we had switched on in our
experiment so the more factors we had
switched on
the more biodiversity we lost in these
soils and the lower were the soil
processes and soil-borne ecosystem
functions
now this was really weird because the
single factors that we had applied had
either positive effects negative effects
or neutral effects
but when you combine them what came out
was a
just steady decrease in biodiversity and
ecosystem functions and process rates
and how can you explain that the answer
we don't know
it's actually we have no idea what's
going on there but i'm gonna try to
explain to you like i would explain it
to my mom
so you have a job in this ecosystem your
job is to decompose organic matter if
you live in the soil as a as a fungus or
a bacterium let's say this is your job
so transfer the
situation to you you have a job you have
to write a report that that line that
report has a deadline
okay so now three things happen i'm
gonna only go three not ten but you can
complete it in your mind so the one
thing that happens is your super fun
neighbor
shows up at your door with a bottle of
red wine and he wants to celebrate now
this is very positive because you want
to celebrate with that neighbor
but you also have a report to write with
a deadline
and so then
a neutral thing happens your dad asks
you a complicated tax question
but this is neutral you have to answer
to that question it doesn't take much
effort but you still have to do it it
also takes effort away from
doing your task writing the report and
then of course whenever you rely on the
internet it cuts out at home so you have
an internet outage
and that is a negative effect now these
things all happen to you at the same
time so it doesn't really matter if it's
positive or negative or neutral the end
result is this adds to your stress now
imagine this would be happening in the
soil
now imagine also this happens in the
soil you're not just one person you are
one species of many species in our tiny
little soil samples we had thousands of
species of bacteria and we had hundreds
of species of fungi and god knows how
many protists we measured them all
so this is slightly more complicated
than what i have depicted here
now this is
in the end
kind of bad news sorry
because with more factors and we have
all these factors this is not fantasy
this is what's really happening we will
be losing biodiversity and soul
ecosystem functions and process rates
but there is also a silver lining i
think this is very important to
emphasize because it means that if we
can switch off some of these factors
that are inevitably acting we will be
moving back along this line and maybe
towards more biodiversity and better
ecosystem process rates
but what's important is that we move the
conversation and this is how i finish up
to global change we cannot really afford
to just talk about climate change
and we also need to do more research and
yesterday we we've started this
experiment here this is
the first global change experiment that
i know with 10 factors so you can see
open top chambers here for passive
warming and rain out shelters are for
drought and the other eight treatments
are
soil borne treatments um so this is how
we hope to find out more um about these
many many factors this is actually on
the humboldt university property even
though i met a few
dua
thanks very much
all right
thank you so much again there is the
opportunity for some questions and i'll
take the opportunity to ask you the
first question
if most research has only looked at one
factor or two factor
and
the results of your experiment what does
that those results what do they mean to
all this research that has been done
does your experiment render them in a
way
senseless because they have not really
looked at the whole story
not really because the single factor
experiments are of course also important
to understand mechanism
and we need to understand mechanism if
we want to predict
now
the downside so to speak because we
never solve everything with one
experiment of this approach is that we
don't really know which factors and
which combination of factors are really
responsible for the effects we used all
kinds of statistical models to tease
that out but we cannot really determine
that because there's too many factors
that are acting so now we still need
also the single factor experiments and
the combinations of maybe one or two
because this is the way we find out
about mechanisms of how these factors
act and actually what i did is based on
all these single factor uh studies i
went ahead and did a classification like
a phylogenetic tree
of all these global change factors like
really a tree of similarity of all the
global change factors based on traits
and we could use that based on basically
the single factor research to predict a
little bit of what came out of this
experiment thank you so much any
questions from the audience
i guess we are trained to sort of sort
our things as the most important things
first like i mean out of the factors
what's the most important one deal with
that one first
and the second question would be are i
mean things are related of course
climate change in the end is not a
factor something that things start with
but it's something that caused by other
things like um co2
um does it make sense to sort things
that way
yeah no i think it does i mean it
doesn't preclude the fact that they are
also
related like what you had explained for
example this is this is also correct
um and i get this response a lot you
know haven't we really covered our basis
by looking at warming and drought and
elevated co2 and nitrogen deposition
from the atmosphere those are the big
four almost all papers are on this big
four
and the answer is i don't think so
i think we need also these other factors
because they are real they really occur
like our lab works a lot on microplastic
and actually in our sea grant
and um
micro plastic is also everywhere it
literally rains down from the atmosphere
even the most remote regions on this
planet because it comes off your cloaks
it's literally everywhere and so this is
this can this argument can be made for
many other factors so i think we are
missing
some very very important results by just
looking at the big four as they are
called i think we need to extend that
set of factors
thank you so much
we'll take in those two questions uh
professor bugano and then you and we'll
take them together and then we'll get
back to you please go ahead thank you
you didn't mention at all one thing
which i i'm sure you're very very much
aware of which is the the the value of
thresholds that is
uh there is a plasticity which means
that for a certain range basically
even if there is a difference it doesn't
make a difference but then the when you
pass a certain threshold then all of a
sudden something things can change
drastically
can you also have a look at this with
your experiment we did
maybe we just take the second question
then and then you will answer thank you
all very plausible and all very scary at
the same time so i have another question
to evolution so microbial systems are
known to be extremely versatile in
adaptivity and in evolution so if you
have combinatorial stresses on them do
we expect an acceleration of
evolutionary trajectories that we
haven't seen before
please go ahead
so to the first question we we did look
for tipping point behavior in our data
set and we found some in some evidence
that there may be tipping points going
on but it was actually
not the break point in our data but it
was a really a continuous decline which
was really surprising
um but you're
mentioning another point that it is
actually we only looked at two levels of
each factor
and the levels were actually um
chosen specifically to be very
conservative so we didn't add like a lot
of this material or we didn't increase
temperature by a huge amount we didn't
have a very severe drought
and we we tried to have these levels
informed by actually measured
values that would be present in germany
for example maybe going a little higher
to simulate a hot spot so it was a
pretty conservative approach but what we
are missing actually is really these
response surfaces
now as you can imagine if you have
so many factor combinations this was a
pretty difficult experiment to do if you
also have different levels of each
factors it gets very quickly out of hand
but we are
we are working on that a little bit we
have some ideas on how we can actually
combine these more response surface
approaches with many many levels for one
factor at least and then maybe the other
factors get switched on on block or off
so this is the way i think we're going
to do this in the next experiments but
we had definitely
in um yeah we were thinking about this
all along because this is an obvious
point because we only have two levels of
each factor
about evolution
we have some people in the lab actually
this was one of the things in the erc
grant to work on evolution but
this part with the multiple factors we
haven't addressed yet i am quite sure it
will change evolutionary trajectories
and i'm quite sure that even after the
six weeks of this little short-term
incubation we will have had evolutionary
changes in those microbes no doubt
but how to predict those and what are
the consequences of these evolutionary
changes for the outcomes that we see
that i don't know yeah
matthias thank you so much
and you can just see he's really excited
he's still excited and he has has fun
you know doing the research he is doing
so thank you so much
and we're moving on to the humboldt
universitat susana schreiber as a
professor at the institute for
theoretical biology at the umbert
university and employs mathematics to
understand how our brain works as
theoretical neuroscientists she also
chairs the bernstein network of
computational neuroscience and is vice
chair of the german ethics council and
she received the erc consolidator grant
title of a presentation how the
personality of nerve cells shape shapes
the rhythms in our brain please go ahead
thanks so much thank you very much it's
a pleasure be to be here tonight i'm
particularly grateful to the erc funding
so it's very great to see
the new president here and i'm going to
tell you a little bit about this project
which is about the brain and what you
see here to start with is a network of
symbolized cells and what we know is
that the connections between the cells
are the really important things so when
we learn then these connections change
that's actually quite intuitive so the
question is about who talks to whom and
if you think about a scenario like that
then you'll see or understand that it
makes a difference if you look at
different situations here the outcome in
the end if these people have to solve a
problem may be different from the first
example to the second example that's
what all neuroscientists
take for granted something that is not
so well
taken into account often but is the
creator of my lab is that there are
personalities so if you think of this
example here then you see even though
you may have this constellation here
then if these people are very accessible
and very empathetic you may get a
different result
if they have to solve a problem compared
to if they were all choleric and
uncaring so neural personality that's
the same for the neurons matters a lot
not just who talks to whom
so if we think about nerve cell
communication what does that actually
mean so how do neurons talk what they do
is they elicit these pulses that you see
here of electrical activity
they pass them on to the other cells and
the other cells listen
and
what we know is that we have three
personality types of cells i'm going to
put that a bit simpler here we have the
blue cells which i call the slow start
is you have the jump starters and the it
depends starters the slow start to start
with pulses once they're triggered that
follow or that that are not so many and
then
you have to excite them more to get more
pulses the jump starters they if they're
triggered they jump right away to a high
pulse rate and it depends starters are a
mixture between the two
now this is not what they're termed in
literature
actually we have known two of these
types since the 1950s so that's the
classical type 1 and type 2 described by
hodgkin and this one is called the
homoclinic and it was kind of
rediscovered by us in the sense that
everybody believed they are not there in
the brain but they have special
properties and you can
find them mathematically you can predict
they must be there and i'm going to tell
you why these properties are so special
because that's the core of the ground
so
you may not be surprised to hear that
for communication it's not only about
talking but a lot is about listening
and that's the same for nerve cells so
if you look at the type two here then
this is a
kind of self-absorbed guy because if he
elicits a pulse which you see here with
the star then it first needs to recover
from his own speech before it can listen
to others because what this curve here
shows is when does it listen best to the
other cells and you see there's a
temporal delay here whereas the
homoclinic one he's very special because
what happens is if he talks if he
elicits a pulse then he can right away
listen to the other cells
and that gives a very nice property if
you join these cells in the network so
think of 10 neurons coupled in a network
here in an all-too-old fashion and then
what you see here is the pulses that
these 10 neurons elicit
here they are kind of disordered if you
now take the same network and those are
now these homoclinic personalities of
cells then you see that they all fire in
concert so we have a synchronized
activity
and what this means is if you look at
the level of the eeg signal so the some
signal of activity in the brain or the
local some some activity then if you sum
these up here you won't see a brain
rhythm or only a very weak one whereas
here if they're synchronized you'll see
these large
elevations these large oscillations so
these guys these homoclinic cells with
this personality they can give yield or
they can give very strong brain rhythms
so one last thing i need to tell you for
you to see what is the nice thing about
the ground is
nerve cells can actually switch their
personality so it's not fixed but they
can turn from a type one neuron for
example to a homoclinic neuron
one thing that we found is that a
temperature increase suffices to do that
so when you increase temperature then
normally a type 1 will become a
homoclinic neuron
what follows from this is also the brain
rhythm
is changing so you see here a very weak
brain rhythm
if you then increase the temperature
actually only by two degrees celsius you
start to see that you have these really
large elevations so you get a strong
brain rhythm in the eg signal
and this is what this grant is about so
we want to understand how personality
switches can give rise to very strong
brain rhythms because this may be
interesting for pathologies like
epilepsy it may be one mechanism how
epilepsy can be triggered in its initial
phase
so the thing we're going to look at is
the trigger factors i already mentioned
temperature here and the another one is
really nice and that is the um
if the brain does not have enough energy
so if the neurons get exhausted
then the neurons um also turn into
homogenic spikers and this is something
that we often see in disease so we often
see that either temperatures increase
that can trigger an epileptic seizure or
that energy goes down and there's many
more factors
so just to summarize
we're going to look in this project at
the mechanisms that can trigger these
brain rhythms based on neuronal
personalities at the trigger factors and
we hope to find that the brain is full
of homoclinic personalities which we
don't know yet what we use to achieve
that or to discover that is actually
mathematics you see that on the left
hand side so i'm not an
experimental neuroscientist i'm using
mathematics mathematical simulations to
understand these things and to come up
with predictions
yeah and i'm very happy to take your
questions and thank you for listening
thank you suzanne schreiber
are there any questions from the
audience
can hardly see you but i can kind of
guess if somebody is
all right let me
otherwise i would like to start
you said uh could we go back to the last
slide maybe is that possible
last question is the brain full of
on one is it is it full of homoclinic
personalities this one yeah this one the
last question i i don't really get this
i get the first two
but
but why is that important i thought that
they can
change
anyways they can be either this or that
so how is that question relevant if any
cell can be a homoclinic personality at
any given time
the difference is that this is what we
find in theory this is what is what we
find with mathematics where we can
actually really prove that if you start
out with one cell type and you change
these factors you are bound to end up
with the other cell type but that
whether that really is what nature does
because so far since the 50s people have
only found the type 1 and type 2 neurons
only have discussed these and it's very
difficult to distinguish is there this
homoclinic spiker in there not because
he often looks like either type one or
type two and these listening curves
they're very hard to measure so
essentially we don't know in the real
brain whether they are there we predict
from our work they should so just in the
model they should be everywhere exactly
but we're going to find out with in
collaboration with experimentalists
whether that's the case or not all right
thank you
yeah please go ahead
sorry you just mentioned the word
experimentalists can you tell us
something about what kind of
experimental data you're comparing your
work to
so we have we're very fortunate to have
several collaborators here in berlin um
what we start with is slice work so
where you take the brain you slice it
and then it's an in vitro approach
because there we can control the cells
in isolation so we can cut synaptic
pharmacologically
rule out the synaptic connections and
then can start to manipulate what we
hope to go for is in the end also in
vivo approach where we can use in vivo
data and use machine learning techniques
to because that's difficult because we
have also the network input but we hope
to learn how to classify these neuronal
personalities even if the network is
intact to distinguish them
yeah one question by contact zigler we
learned that there's only three types of
cells there type one type two and homo
clinic how do you know are you sure or
is this just a simple model
it's not just a simple model but it's a
simplification a very pretty drastic one
for the purpose of this talk so this is
true for
the regularly firing cells you know that
that you know fire in a nice rhythm we
also have other types of cells that have
bursting patterns and so on and they
they can be classified into different
classes so i'm not talking about those
but um the three classes are
as you're a mathematician i'm allowed to
answer this question it
depends on the mathematic bifurcation
that underlies the initiation of the
limit cycles of this onset of repetitive
aspirin and spiking and there's only
three types that yield a roughly
constant amplitude there's a fourth type
but then it starts out with tiny spikes
and that's what i'm not
looking at so three mathematical types
all right
thank you so much suzanne schreiber
so let's move on to the technical
university
is the founding head of the remote
sensing image analysis group at the
faculty of
electrical engineering and computer
science of the tu berlin and she also
leads the big data analytics for earth
observation research group at the berlin
institute for the foundations of
learning and data you perform research
in the field of processing and analysis
of large-scale earth observation and
data acquired by airborne and
satellite-borne systems you received an
erc starting grant and you will now tell
us about your research accurate and
scalable processing of big data in earth
observation professor bighim dimier
please go ahead
[Applause]
thank you very much for the nice
introduction it's a great pleasure for
me to be here to present our initial
research discoveries on my big art
project
so
okay
it is all on accurate and scalable
processing of big data in our
observation and at our team we
especially do foundational research in
terms of big data management and machine
learning for earth observation
so it's very important because with the
advances in satellite technology
remote sensing data archives are growing
at exceptionally fast rate not only in
volume but also in diversity
as an example with the copernicus
program that is the european flagship
satellite initiative for earth
observation sentinel satellites acquire
almost 12 terabytes of data per day and
at the moment the copernicus data
archives has size of almost 20 petabytes
so the large-scale earth observation
data is the great source of information
for several different earth observation
applications
and the information that we can discover
by analyzing satellite images can be
very helpful for several different
applications to monitor the health of
our planet
let me give you an example
so here you see a sentinel-2 image that
is a multi-spectral image acquired after
a very big forest fire on the southern
part of france so the brown area here
that you see is representing the burned
forest areas as you know analyzing burnt
forest areas is helpful for climate
change and ecological studies
and if we can find old bald forest areas
for example given in a geographical
location or duration of a specific time
or so on
this can significantly contribute to
studies on climate change and ecology so
this kind of study can be done by
digging this earth observation data
archives because this information is
hidden there but it is a challenge
because
we need scalable approaches to handle
these petabytes of data plus we need
accurate approaches that can handle
the complex content of multi-modal
heterogeneous earth observation data
archives and actually this is the main
aim of my bigger project where we are
developing search engines search engines
that can operate on the semantic content
of the satellite data here you see the
application in terms of forest fire but
we are developing systems that can
deal with several different applications
so it's independent from the selected
application field
so
the methods and algorithms that we are
developing contribute to the
foundational research
in terms of knowledge discovery
for
querying and indexing multimodal earth
observation data
um we are recently in contact with space
agencies in europe in particular
european space agency to deploy our
tools into their systems because before
big earth
the operational earth observation
systems
was operating only on the keywords okay
not on the schematic content of the
satellite data but when we consider
large-scale data it was not very
efficient sufficient okay so with
biggert we are changing the paradigm in
this line
okay
so um
independently from the earth observation
application that we are dealing one of
the most critical issue was to have
access to training data
so this is very important if you are
dealing with machine learning deep
learning you need a large amount of data
and it is very difficult if you are
dealing with earth observation
applications
so to handle this problem
to drive our knowledge discovery systems
for a search and query purposes
we develop bigger tonight okay so big
alternate it's the large-scale sentinel
archive that includes data coming from
10 european countries and actually we
are very proud of its success since it
is first released almost two years ago
it has been downloaded 10 000 times more
than 10 000 times by many organizations
including european space agency nasa
german aerospace center and so on
it is a publicly available it is a
website that is bigger.net
and also it is available on google earth
engine transfer flow and radiant ml hub
okay
so uh in order to help to the users to
interactively visualize our data set we
recently developed a portal that we call
it as big art net portal
so that portals thanks to the
technologies that it uses
it allows the users to efficiently and
effectively discover the big arts net by
just selecting the geographical area
by just selecting polygons around the
geographical area of interest the two
returns the images to the user with
specific characteristics for example you
can see land use land cover clusters
present in the area and also the
statistics driven based on this
information
okay
so in a nutshell big earth is aiming to
develop accurate and scalable systems
for indexing our earth to discover in a
quick way an accurate way information
about it
and i believe that
the systems that we are developing
through bigertnet will significantly
contribute to recent initiative of
european commission that is destination
earth destination art is aiming to
develop digital tvs of different
aspects of our earth system
and then infrastructures models tools to
deal with this data and we are hoping
that they will be also taking advantage
of our tools that we are developing in
the zrc project
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much that was quick yeah
please go ahead first question by
professor leptin
so your training data set is interesting
i mean you must you must
give the ground truth of what's in those
data somebody has to say what the
machine is supposed to learn
so but you can only give things that you
already know about those data
so how do you discover new things or how
does the machine learn to discover
so when when we deal with satellite data
if it is a small scale problem like
classification of um
berlin okay then it is not that
challenging right but when you do large
scale analysis
um it's the challenge to collect this
data and it is almost impossible to do
it manually so that was one of the
challenging situation
and then at the
time that we started with our grand
european environment agency made public
a current database of 2018 for whole
europe
so
they provided land to use vancouver
class labels
and uh i think
we were lucky that
it just came
in our first year and then we uh use
copernicus data satellite data of
european commission and we map this with
the
labels provided by european environment
agency
so
and then we made also publicly available
our
models trained on big earth nets
and that made a big impact
um yeah so the labels are provided by
european environment agency but of
course they were not targeting
our project it was for other purposes
but
we took advantage of it
thank you so much
any more questions
i seem to always have questions so um
you describe this basically as searching
data and finding things in this data but
one of the things that is certainly
interesting like if you take the
copernicus data is to integrate them
over time to to see change and of course
to discover that so uh that's sort of
one question and the other one is how is
something like that map map to something
like google earth which of course gives
you pictures again a rather static thing
and i'm just thinking of that because
google earth apparently was
copied from a berlin project terror
vision
so
and these are really very good questions
so uh of course we are very much
interested in change detection um
and actually this
this search engine we are adopting it
for change retrieval so here for example
i have shown you aquarium burnt forest
but query can be also the frustration
which which requires at least two images
before and after first deforestation
right and then to we can model these
pairs of images in the query and search
for similar deforestated areas so i
think it's a very timely and interesting
field in this line and it is in our
agenda
um so for the for the google earth so
google earth engine took our because our
data set is publicly available for
research purposes and google earth
engine
provided our data set and pre-trained
machine learning models under google
earth engine
and
yeah that's it but we are
so we
we are closely working with european
space agency i should admit this and uh
yeah we would like to make it um
a european search engine for satellite
image search and retrieval yeah
very exciting thank you so much big um
demi thank you very much
so there's one more partner in the
alliance and it's the charity
so the next presentation comes from a
researcher from the charity soyuzugada
connecting the brain with machines this
is his research focus
go ahead you you found out that brain
control devices cannot only improve
quality of life and paralysis but may
soon transform the treatment of brain
disorders such as depression addiction
or dementia you also receive the erc
starting grant and we are really looking
forward to hearing more about your
research go ahead it's very wonderful to
be here tonight
it is estimated that
more than one billion people on this
planet suffer from a disorder of the
brain
for example depression anxiety stroke
multiple sclerosis or dementia
but despite all
tremendous technological progress we
still don't have the tools to tackle
brain disorders effectively and without
side effects so in my erc funded project
i am developing the next generation
neurotechnologies that will improve
quality of life
and restore brain functions across
various brain disorders
the project builds on
the latest advances in brain computer
interfaces
so these brain computer interfaces
translate brain activity into control
commands of a digital device for example
here you see a patient controlling a
prosthetic arm to grasp a coffee and
drink or you can even use these
bcis
for
controlling several
prosthetic devices
however implantation of these
microelectrodes entails the risk of
infections and bleedings and there is no
certification to use these devices on
the long term
and none of these patients have ever
used these
these technologies outside of the
laboratory in their daily life
so in my research my team and i we are
developing non-invasive brain computer
interfaces that do not require a
surgical procedure
here you see a number of quadriplegic
patients who are all in a wheelchair and
who are unable to grasp with their own
fingers they are unable to grasp a book
a cup or
a piece of paper
so we have equipped these patients with
a neural exoskeleton that would
translate their brain activity
associated with the intention to close
their fingers into actual closing
motions and here you can see that these
patients can securely grasp and
manipulate these different objects of
daily life
and
restore their hand function the system
could also be used outside of the
laboratory so this gentleman went out to
a restaurant and ate for the first time
after several years with a fork
we asked the patients what they would
like to do with this new ability
and
there is
another patient who asked for a plate of
potato chips because he hasn't eaten
these potato chips for many years on his
own so here you can see in his face
how this technology can
improve quality of life
now we have used this technology also in
chronic stroke patients who were unable
to move their fingers sometimes for
years or even decades
and after one month of daily training we
were very surprised to see that some of
the patients could move the fingers
again and we were of course very
interested to find out what happened in
their brain and what we found is that
the brain activity that was associated
with the intention to move the paralyzed
fingers
reorganized after one month of this
daily training and this reorganization
correlated with the clinical improvement
now there is no reason to believe that
this principle cannot also be used for
restoration of other brain functions
than movements for example memory
formation cognitive control or emotion
regulation
and
the state-of-the-art brain computer
interfaces on the conceptual level they
translate brain activity into sensory
feedback and the sensory feedback
influences brain activity
and we have found that this closed loop
leads to functional and structural
reorganization of the brain now the next
generation brain computer interfaces
they will also translate brain activity
into sensory feedback but brain activity
associated with brain functions like
memory formation emotion
regulation or cognitive control
we will
add adaptive brain stimulation to foster
stabilization and improvement of brain
function
now the big challenge is to identify the
neural substrates of these different
brain disorders because we can't simply
ask someone to be depressed and then
stop it like a voluntary movement so how
can we understand what these neural
substrates are a possible way is to
record brain activity in the millisecond
to millisecond range and apply brain
stimulation and then observe changes in
brain function and behavior
now this would allow us to understand
the causal link between brain activity
and brain function or behavior
but of course there's a problem when we
record brain activity in the millisecond
to millisecond range and we apply brain
stimulation there are huge artifacts
that make it impossible to really reach
out these physiological responses now in
our erc project we have overcome this
problem and achieved a
breakthrough
in applying electric stimulation
non-invasive electric brain stimulation
while we could restore millisecond to
millisecond
brain activity in real time so that's
very important in real time so we can do
this in real time it's not
after processing but we can do this in
real time and we applied this new
technology in
for example an application where we
target frontal theta oscillations that
are linked to memory formation
often often
often affected in the elderly or
patients with dementia and when we did
this we could find that indeed
millisecond precise targeting of these
frontal theta oscillations can improve
memory performance in the image or
picture recognition task while
open loop simulation or non-specific
stimulation did not
now
a critical point here is that we have to
increase spatial resolution of neural
imaging tools so this frontal theta
oscillations that are very easy to catch
but if it comes to other brain functions
very difficult to understand the neural
substrates so here you see the latest
generation of quantum sensors and these
quantum sensors can offer non-invasive
assessment of brain activity at
unprecedented spatial resolution and
here in berlin with the
physical station shibundus unstyled
we're implementing these new sensors
into the erc project and we'll build the
first of its kind quantum bci close to
brain stimulation platform
what we also do is we are developing
novel brain stimulation techniques based
on temporal interference of magnetic
fields that can reach deep into the
brain tissue where until now we could
only
reach with implantation of electrodes
with support of the berlin institute of
health we have filed an international
patent on this on this new
technology and we will implement and
validate this stimulation in the next
two years
now of course if we
use it's very clear if we use this
technology there are a number of
neuroethical
questions that
are raised
and
we of course also address them in the
project
now with this
i'd like to conclude that i'm convinced
that especially with the support of the
erc
science can exert a profound
transform transformative effect on how
we treat brain disorders
effectively and without side effects
thank you
thank you so much
um
the the slide about the ethics you know
you were very brief on that so tell us
about the ethics a little bit yes so i
like very much what you said about
technology and how it could be also used
in applications that are not favorable
for
um
well the future of humankind
and now if it comes to these
technologies we are also faced with this
um issue of course because um if we are
for example manipulating brain activity
in in ways that people are not aware of
subtle
then of course
there are a lot of questions that are
coming up and for example chile has now
a new law
that protects so-called neural rights so
that everyone has a right to have
a protected
free will for example and
of course we need to do more research
and
we need to anticipate what this kind of
technology could be used for in a few
years because you have you've probably
noticed that a lot of private money is
going into this field of brain computer
interfaces elon musk has invested a lot
of money into this
but that's the invasive approach but i
think from this invasive approach we'll
learn so much about the brain that also
non-invasive tools will be able to do
these things that we are doing now in in
the medical
field where it's very clear that it's an
imperative to use this technology to
improve quality of life but obviously
this technology could be also used um in
other ways it's very important to
protect privacy
data security is a very issue very very
very important issue cyber security if
all this data is read out and stored on
some server we need to make sure that
it's really safe
thank you so much
you have a question
please go ahead i mean there's a
microphone
you know you don't okay are there any
questions so please go ahead
okay so thank you very much for this
really impressive talk i was wondering
compared to the earlier approaches or
the invasive approaches what is the very
thing that enables you to do that
non-invasively so can you can you say
that in a few sentences to the lay
audience well exactly i mean your work
actually shows that there are neuronal
pools
that are responsible like responsive to
external
stimulation and when we use for example
closed-loop stimulation we can target
these neuronal populations
non-invasively using magnetic fields for
example that are temporal temporally
interfering at some spot in the brain
and as these are larger neuronal pools
that are responsive for
certain frequencies
we can target these different functions
for example motor function
or memory but of course it will be much
more interesting to go even deeper into
this and have more focality and that
non-invasively is right now a very um
a huge problem of course but with these
quantum sensors for example i'm i'm
pretty um positive that we can achieve
that with higher spatial resolution and
especially higher bandwidth so we can
record neuronal
neuronal oscillations up to 400 hertz
non-invasively and that's really a
unique opportunity
let me let me just follow up on that
you only observe what's happening now or
can you explain what's happening when
you
trigger something
well there are there's a lot of studies
that suggest how physiology links to
behavior but we have we have heard there
are so many factors that in the end
you can only have theories about this
linkedin it's all correlative so in my
research i'm trying really to make a
step into causality so we are changing
brain activity in a specific way and we
know exactly how we change it because we
are recording brain activity at the same
time and see how the stimulation is
changing the brain and then we observe
what the result is and of course we use
their machine learning algorithms to
cluster
different brain states
and different brain brain functions and
changes in brain function so that's what
we do but in the end
every brain is different so if you look
into neuroscience you have the barrages
potentially you all have these barrages
potentials some very basic physiological
responses but all your brains are
different
yeah and so we need to be on a
personalized
level where we use this kind of
technology to understand on the personal
individual
level what's going on in your specific
brain
thank you
any more questions
good ziggler your question this round
so again two questions one is what is
quantum about these quantum sensors and
the other question is why do you use
human brains wouldn't it be much easier
to start with i don't know bees or mice
well that's these are very good
questions so the first question is where
is the quantum
so um
usually when you record neuromagnetic
activity um there is a technology called
magnetoencephalography and to do this
because the magnetic fields are so
minute
you need superconducting
devices that have to be cooled with
helium so that was the technology that
was state of the art until five years
ago
and because they had to be cooled you
had to be
four to seven centimeters away from the
cortex
so very far away from from these fields
and now we have vapor cells
filled with rubidium and there are two
lasers who are pumping into the gas and
you can change the spin of these
rubidium atoms and you can reach out
the b field the environmental field that
is actually
affecting the the spin of the rubidium
atoms and that is the quantum in all
this and here in germany we're
especially especially now focusing on on
diamond synthetic diamond magnetometers
um so right now these these optical
magnetometers that's the name for this
rubidium cell technology is mainly done
in the u.s but it has been developed
actually in berlin at the ptb the
physical station bundesliga
so my aim is to really
bring this technology to applications
here in berlin and also have of course
also companies who are going to invest
into this technology you know to make it
available for humans and that's the next
question so my my i have a lifetime of
i hope maybe three or four decades
and
i understand the complexity of i'm a
psychiatrist of humans and
i see that you know if we want to bring
this technology to to humans we need to
do it now
and um i'm very
you can do mice model you can all do
this it's all very nice however the jump
into the real application in humans is
always
unclear so my approach would be to to
make this jump already now of course
under conditions where we know that we
are not doing any harm
now if if you come to my practice here
in the charities not far away
we are using neuromodulation for example
in depression and there are patients who
were depressed for many years they had
taken medicine like drugs have all these
side effects and it didn't work so they
come to my to my practice and we use
neuromodulation and we can take them out
of of depression and and that is what
drives me so my what drives me what
motivates me is to use this technology
in in the clinical case
i hope i answered your question
so you sucked up thank you so much thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was fun wasn't it i mean four very
fascinating personalities fascinating
research they are doing
and the
the good thing is you can just continue
asking them questions
because we're wrapping up this official
event now but there will be a reception
following in a minute and they will stay
around so you can just go up to them you
can just talk to them ask them more
questions and i think gunther ziegler
has some more questions so
they're happy to answer them there will
be something to drink just stay around
celebrate the signs celebrate the bua
celebrate the erc stay around here and
it's in the dinosaurs
hall that's what you want in mia okay so
we go there together so you don't get
lost in this great museum and they don't
have to spend the night in the museum
it's in the dinosaurs hall and we just
leave there together thank you so much
again our four researchers for being
here for providing us with some insight
into your science thank you so much also
to maria leptin to sabina kunst and
please stay around be here for another
hour or so thank you so much for being
here have a great evening
[Applause]